You have always wanted to learn about
category theory or as mathematicians call it
generalized abstract nonsense. Now what
is category theory?
Category theory is the mathematicians way
to do object oriented programming or
design patterns. A category is simply
built from objects and morphisms and the
morphisms have to satisfy certain laws.
In particular when you have a morphism
from a to b
and another morphism from b to c, you
have to have a morphism
directly from a to c as well.
Let's take a step back and take this
category
and make categories as objects
so that we get this picture. Here we
have the
categories now as objects and we need to
have a notion of morphism.
That morphism is called a functor and
the category is called
the category of small categories. If we
look
at the rules for functors, what we
recognize
is that the functor when applied to object
is really
a generic type and when it is applied
to morphisms
we see that it's the familiar map
function. We can take
yet another step back and look at
functors as objects.
And when we use functors as objects, we
need
again a notion of morphism and those
morphisms are called
natural transformations. And if we look
at that with our developer glasses
we see that natural transformations are
nothing more
than generic functions. And this category
by the way
is called the functor category. Again
the morphisms in the functor category,
these natural transformations
have to satisfy particular laws and
the usual way to write those is with a
commuting diagram like this.
So if you go from the top left to the
bottom right, you can go in two ways
and the law says that it doesn't matter
which direction you take.
Well, I know which direction you should
take.
You should come and do this MOOC.
See you soon
in cyberspace!